bom dia boa tarde boa noite de hoje vou
falar em português sobre é a
aprendizagem de línguas e sobretudo é
por que certas pessoas têm dificuldade
em aprender línguas é o digo sempre que
se tem é que o mais importante é essa
que precisa ter confiança precisa ter a
vontade é é preciso gostar da língua que
está aprendendo é essas coisas são muito
muito importante é não é quase 70% por
114 a influenciar é o sucesso
a segunda coisa é e e o tempo passar
muito tempo com a língua
lendo falando é isso é muito importante
a coisa é de envolver a capacidade de
estar atentos ao que acontecer é eu
falou é muitas vezes sobre essas coisas
é a motivação para aprender uma língua
uma língua nova' novo a ter sucesso na
nova é conseguir mas tem muitas pessoas
é que têm a vontade que tem a motivação
a não consiga a aprender uma segunda
língua porque eu acho que o mais
importante é o feito que eles não têm
feito isso que não tem a experiência de
mudar se tornar se uma pessoa que fala
uma outra língua
eu falo mais ou menos a outras como o ru
português não é se uma lei que fala
muito bem mas eu sei que sc
eu vou passar o suficiente é tempo com a
língua portuguesa
vou acabar para poder falar português
tenho sou como vencido mas muita é
muitas pessoas é que não tem essa
experiência a confiança que podem
conseguir a falar
uma outra língua fluentemente por isso
quando eles estudem todas as frustrações
é o feito todas as coisas que vamos
aprender vamos esquecer que é muitas
vezes no não vamos a entender muitas
vezes nos ramos do poder é sexo
sabe como é gostar ia ser presa porque
em nossas línguas nativas
somos adultos
falamos é perfeitamente livremente
podemos se expressar mas em línguas
estrangeiras
sempre temos dificuldades então
aprendemos e esquecemos não podemos
dizer o que queremos dizer é muitas
coisas na intendente então isso só as
frustrações da aprendizagem de línguas
mas se vocês sabem se você acredita que
terá sucesso
então todas essas frustrações não é não
é importante
doc crença ea que você o um dia vá poder
falar e nessa outra língua além disso é
o e mail quando é costurado um na língua
faço sempre coisas agradáveis agradáveis
escutou lei o sobre temas que para mim
são interessantes
a cultura não há uma outra cultura a
história do país
outras coisas desse é generosa então me
o processo da aprendizagem em si mesmo é
agradável
então a as frustrações não são
importantes porque eu sei que é quando
aprendemos uma língua
o processo é longo é longo longe da
longa longo que precisa tempo muito
tempo que o cérebro
vá aprender vós o vosso servo aprender
mas precisa tempo e também eu sei que eu
não quero passar a língua passado na
aula num não acredito que um professor
pode explicar a gramática melhor do que
o livro que eu posso comprar e ler
quando quero e as coisas que não posso
ler outra vez eu não quero depender do
professor para as explicações de
gramática
eu sei que somente depois de muito a
experiência com a língua de pé depois de
ter escutado muito
ele é um goleiro muito lindo muito as
explicações de gramática é vou começar é
e então eu vou falar com outros
estudantes diz a melhor
dodô eu não quero escutar falantes da
língua eu prefiro escutar e limpei 3
escutar só de castiel é coisa
interessante para mim é eu
por exemplo é com o português
eu sou muito consciente que fala muito
mal o português quem ditou de portunhol
mas eu sei é que tenho há a vontade de
aprender português
eis as duas semanas tem é escutado muito
o time português melhor agora que é a
dose semanas
e ó paí ó em tendo mais e não falou
muito mas o melhor é esse eo cação a
possibilidade de passar umas semanas mas
brasil é brasil com o tempo escutando e
falando em vôo miami é entretanto é como
a falar como falou com muitos zeros e
continuar a usar cores é a língua e
pouco a pouco vou melhorar me tenho isso
a confiança a acredito que é muito
muitas pessoas não têm essa confiança no
não sabem como é é estudar e não
acredita não acreditam que vão conseguir
a falar fluentemente uma outra língua
então eu digo vocês têm que acreditar
tem que ter motivação tem que ter
confiança tem que passar o tempo tem que
procurar coisas interessantes para vocês
para escutar para ler a tem que falar
com heróis em não se preocupa se você
fala com erros um nó porque o cérebro
pouco a pouco vá a corrigir não
precisa de as conexões delta outra
pessoa
se a outra pessoa vá corrigir muito bem
mas isso não é necessário não precisa
dessa coleção porque o cérebro ou vá
pouco a pouco se és e corrigir
se você pode de se renovar é dublê a
capacidade de estar atento é a
capacidade deve estar atento
é com muita é experiência como a lei mas
a ala dura e também com a determinação e
quando você vai escutar uma frase que
vocês sabem por exemplo eu sabem em
português
tenho dificuldades com um antigo outras
coisas em louca tratar de prestar
atenção quando estou escutando lendo
então esse a eu a fazer essas coisas
porque tem a confiança que vou conseguir
então eu é que pessoas que não têm a
experiência de ter aprendido 2 234 em
mas tem que continuar
tem que seguir vocês terão sucesso muito
prazer é obrigado
é um até logo